why as water so cheap is it priced right
and i think it is obviously I'm talking
to experts here so you know I'm not
surprising many people in the room but
from an industrial side from the you
know the guy who's trying to run power
plants you feed district energy systems
water prices vary drastically and
fundamentally the prices do not reflect
the all-in cost of water they don't you
know the energy business if you look at
the cost of an electron has done a you
know i'll call it much better job at
pricing in the cost of energy i'm an
energy guy my water colleagues might
debate this with me but i think they
generally agree so this direct cost is a
financial cost building wastewater
treatment plants pumping stations pipes
there's environmental costs waste
generated from water processing
degradation of return streams fertilizer
you know runoff from irrigation and in
this resource cost what is the cost when
you deplete a resource ok you can price
the damn can you price the drought
harder to do particularly when it's on
the other side of a border of your enemy
okay so pricing isn't is a challenge
that's got to be solved water has got to
be priced at a level that will drive
consumption that will drive decision
making just you know for example in the
developed world Germany compared to the
u.s. four times the cost of water
domestic water in Germany is us and it's
not because fundamentally their
processes are less efficient because
they priced it that way